hey guys Pete here today I'm going to do
a video that is a follow up to a video I
did a few months back it's related
indirectly to some of the spoilers that
have been coming out of season 7s
filming locations but don't worry I'm
not going to go into any of those here
if you want to know more about that you
can check out my Game of Thrones Season
7 spoilers playlist to watch those this
will contain spoilers for things that
have happened through season 6 though so
if you're not caught up with the show
you officially been warned with all that
out of the way let's get right into it
as mentioned I did a video a few months
back about Jon Snow riding a dragon
talked about the history of dragons and
Dragon Riders and discussed the theory
of whether it made sense that John would
become a rider appointed the Narus is
three dragons that she's hatched at the
time even though it's been something
I've considered to be a foregone
conclusion I just put the question out
there you know like could he be a dragon
rider this video is more about why he
definitely without a doubt is a rider
and why his mount will be regal
specifically at least according to my
speculation in the show we don't get
much in the way of history regarding
dragons we just know that Daenerys has
some and then it's a big deal it's not
that way because the historical clues
aren't there it's just because it isn't
that important to the story so far in
the Song of Ice and Fire books we get a
lot more details about what rest
Westeros was like before King Robert
took the Iron Throne
we also learned a ton about past
Targaryen kings and their dragons in the
world of Ice and Fire book and the -
George RR Martin's short stories the
rogue prince and the princess and the
Queen for this video I'll do a quick
overview of Dragon Riders as far as
dragons themselves there are a few
different ideas about where they
originated from Septon barth who was a
common born person who became the hand
of king joe harris the first wrote
extensively about them in his work on
natural history he considered several
legends regarding the origins of dragons
the Blair has claimed the Dragons sprang
forth from the 14 flames which is a ring
of volcanoes on the peninsula where
Blair is
meanwhile in Qarth tales state that
dragons came from a second moon in the
sky which was sculpted by the Sun and
act like an A from there a million
dragons poured forth in a shy however
there are many tales some that are super
ancient which claim the Dragons first
appeared on the shadow lands and the
people so ancient they have no name
first-team distract they brought them
they brought them to buleria and taught
the bellarius their arts before
departing from history altogether barth
also put forth the theory the Dragons
were created by the blood mages of the
freehold using wyvern stock those are
similar creatures but they don't breathe
fire so you know they're saying that
there was some sort of blood magic
involved with turning them into the
Dragons that we know now regardless of
any of that the Valerians mastered the
art of riding dragons and using them as
weapons of war to carve out a massive
Empire of course after the doom the only
valerian family that survived with their
dragons were the Targaryen due to their
time in Westeros that they ruled we know
an awful lot about dragons up until most
of them died off in the Civil War known
as the dance of the dress the most
important thing we know related to this
video is that they do not just let
anyone ride them they appear to be very
selective about who they allow to become
their rider I want to emphasize the word
allow here as the in this isn't a
process where there are professional you
know dragon tamers or something like
that who teach them to take a rider they
aren't horses it's a natural process and
if the dragon isn't feeling the person
that's trying to ride them it ends up
with that person died during the dance
several people learned this the hard way
when they tried to mount the unclaimed
dragons that were around that no one was
riding at the time having Valyrian
heritage might be a factor in whether
you live through jumping on a dragon's
back or not but just keep in mind that
there are tons of people that have a
little bit of learning blood passed down
through different bastards and different
things so it's kind of hard to say if
that's the case or not in other words
being descended from the blood of old
Valyria is probably helpful but it
doesn't mean you must be a Targaryen to
ride a dragon the Targaryen one of many
Valyrian dragonlord families
george RR martin has specifically said
that you don't have to be a tart to bond
with a dragon also we have the case of
Quentyn Martell who has Targaryen blood
but still got fried by ragle when he
tried to approach Viserion in the books
what is known is that once the dragon
bonds with the rider that dragon will
not allow anyone else to mount it while
there that rider lives there dragons
will allow new riders once their
previous rider is deceased no rider
though has ever written a different
dragon while his or her current dragon
was locked
make note of that and to drive this
point home listen to this passage from
the princess and the Queen
we shall not pretend to any
understanding of the bond between dragon
and dragon rider wiser heads have
pondered that mystery for centuries we
do know however the dragons are not
horses to be ridden by any man who
throws a saddle on their back
see Rex was the Queen's dragon she had
never known another rider though Prince
Joffrey was known to her by sight and
scent a familiar presence whose fumbling
at her chains excited no alarm the great
yellow she dragon won no part of him a
Strider in his haste to be away before
he could be stopped the Prince had
bolted on to see racks without benefit
of saddle or wet his intent we must
presume was either to fly sea rocks into
battle or more likely to cross the city
to the dragon pit and his own tracks
seas may have cement to loose the other
dragon pit dragons as well Joffrey never
reached the hill of brainy's once in the
air see racks twisted beneath him
fighting to be free of this unfamiliar
rider and from below stones and spears
and arrows flew at him from the hands of
the riders below maddening the dragon
even further 200 feet above flea bottom
Prince Joffrey slid from the Dragons
back in plunge to the earth near
juncture where five Ally's came together
the princes fall came to its bloody end
he crashed first onto a steep pitch roof
before rolling off to fall another 40
feet amidst a shower broken tiles we are
told that the fall broke his back the
shards of of slate rained down about him
like knives that his own sword
tore loose of his hand and pierced him
through the belly in flea bottom men
still speak of the cat of a candle
makers daughter named Robin who cradled
the broken
and her arms and gave him comfort as he
died but there is more of legend than
history in that tale mother forgive me
Joffrey supposedly said with his last
breath though men still argue whether he
was speaking of his mother the queen or
praying to the mother above thus perish
Joffrey valeri Prince of Dragonstone and
heir to the Iron Throne the last of
Queen Rijn era's sons by Lena or
valerian or the last of her bastards by
sir Hart one strong depending on which
truth one chooses to bleed so basically
Joffrey valerian was a dragon rider he
had a dragon he had the ability to ride
but when he tried to mount his mother's
it threw him off her back and killed it
so this is the evidence that you know
it's not all that simple who can or
can't ride a dragon but it is pretty
simple that once someone has claimed one
that no one else can ride that dragon
there seems to be a special bond between
a dragon and its Rider
a dragon might be able to sense when its
current rider is in distress or has died
this is implied in the case of the
dragon dream fire who despite being
locked and chained in the dragon pit
sensed when her rider Elena Targaryen
committed suicide in maegor's holdfast
at the moment of Helena's death dream
fire rose suddenly with the roar that
shook the dragon pit and snapped two of
the chains that bound her so what does
this mean about the three dragons that
are alive in Westeros right now first of
all we know that Dany has claimed Rogan
and she is his rider while she's alive
no one else will ride him that leaves
the other two rhaegal and Viserion who
are named for her two brothers radar and
Viserys
as well as confirmed by brands Tower joy
flashback in season six
John is Rhaegar and Lyanna Starks son he
has the blood of the Dragon and while
there isn't any direct evidence to say
that he's one of the heads of the Dragon
why would it be anybody else by this
point even without the last two books
being written it's hard to form an
opinion about the series overall without
pointing to John and Daenerys as two of
the most important characters and why
set up a backstory with so much lower
related to Dragons prophecy and
everything else if the three dragons
Danny hatched aren't vital to a
conclusive battle at the end I think
that even though george RR martin is
very good at making turns that you
wouldn't expect this isn't one of those
cases it's my opinion and I'm saying
opinion that Jon Snow will become
Raggles
rider because it makes the most sense
there's no smoking gun clue but I think
everything else just points to it I mean
I would love to have some sort of
textual evidence but sometimes your gut
just says this is what's gonna happen
and that's where I'm at with this whole
idea I mean the very heart of it all why
make his parentage such a mystery a
mystery that can in had been solved if
you're going to put three dragons in the
story and then put someone else who
isn't Jon Snow on the back of the Dragon
named after his enigmatic father and
just as food for thought there is one
part of Daenerys house of the undying
vision that I think hint at it
definitely hinted at his parentage
before that was known but I think it
also can be applied to his connection to
Daenerys dragons it reads a blue flower
grew from a [ __ ] in a wall of ice and
filled the air with sweetness this
vision draws a direct connection between
Lyanna stark who loved blue roses the
song of bail the bard who eloped with
Lord Starks daughter leaving a blue rose
in her place and then had a child with
her and Jon Snow who was at the wall
this was an important clue for many
people before R + L equals J was
confirmed in the show the second half of
the quote doesn't get as much attention
but I think it hints to more than
junk.just John's parentage the air being
feel the sweetness sounds a lot like it
means that John will be important very
important to Daenerys herself that could
mean that they would fall in love or
something along those lines or it could
mean that he will be at her side at the
point when she fulfills the role or her
destiny or whatever you want to call it
I tend to lean towards the second option
and think it all just makes sense of
course you guys can tell me why you
think I'm wrong in the comments I could
very well be let me know you think
either way and be sure to LIKE the video
if you enjoyed it since the verse will
give away that we did once so well I've
decided to start another this time I've
given away one of those awesome looking
20th anniversary editions of the book
Game of Thrones
all you have to do is be a subscriber
and leave a comment to enter your
curious about how it all works watch my
Dragonstone video to see how the picking
process went on the last it'll be
exactly the same
this time when I reach 28 thousand
subscribers I'll pick a comment from one
of the videos I put out in that time and
send them that person who left the
comment a copy of the book it's pretty
simple and you might just win so that's
all for today thanks for watching I'll
talk to you soon